What is the image of the polygon
below after the translation is
capital T with the
subscript 5 comma 2?
So that means let's translate
5 in the horizontal direction
and 2 in the vertical direction.
So let's do that.
So I'm going to focus on
this point right over here.
So that point is at
the point 3 comma 3.
If I want to translate five
in the horizontal direction,
the x value is
going to get to 8.
So the x value is
going to 1, 2, 3, 4, 5.
And then we want to
increase the y value by 2.
1, 2.
Let's check our answer.
Let's do a couple more of these.
That was lot of fun.
So here we need to
shift it by negative 8
in the horizontal direction.
So this one right over
here, it's x value is 0,
so we need to go essentially
negative 8, negative 1,
negative 2, or we move to the
left 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, 8.
And then we have to
move it down by 2.
So we have to move
down 1, move it down 2.
And we're done.